my fears that I'm gonna like the way
they look when professionally
photographed then it's just a reminder
that I don't look that way what are you
most insecure about physically what am I
most insecure about physically growing
up I thought I was too pudgy and they
want to take my shirt off at the pool
then now that I'm an adult I think I'm
like too thin and scrawny intellectually
I know that I'm not any less of a man
because I'm not big and strong but it's
hard sometimes to not look at the people
around you and feel less then what I
think makes a man attractive is
athleticism I have a scar that goes up
my knee right here when I cut my knee
open I was in the hospital for like two
and a half weeks and I was recovering
for months I resent the fact that it's
made me weaker I am proportioned like a
skinny person but I have no muscles
instead I just have fat there I don't
have big arms and I'd rather stay under
these sleeves that go all the way to my
elbows I'm always in sleeves to go all
the way to my elbow because then that
covers up every part of my body where
there's supposed to be muscle definition
yeah if I have to open up here I don't
really like the way that I look most of
the time I grew up in an environment
where I was beat up a lot now it's made
fun of then I was kind of told every day
that I was ugly and then in the home
life you know being Korean I was also
told that I could always be improving
how I look I don't talk about my
feelings openly one wouldn't expect me
to have a lot of issues about my body
when I'm just riddled with body and
security normally when we do shoots we
always get really really beautiful
models so when we do I'm recreating a
John Krasinski Men's Health magazine
photo where he looks [ __ ] fine as
hell I'm a comedian right I'm a funny
guy and I've always thought growing up
like funny guys get to look however they
want and that's not it anymore like
Chris Pratt was like my body type and
now he's an action star try it makes the
shoulders a little tough don't look
tough
how do you look tough with your
shoulders John Krasinski same body type
now he's an action star you are supposed
to have this masculine miss to you even
if you're a clown really like feminine
like I know I have very feminine lips I
never felt that attractive until I met
my wife so today I'm recreating a
Cristiano Ronaldo at and he looks
freaking delicious you got some big
shoes to fill he's really good-looking
yes I know
muscles everywhere yes I would
absolutely want to look like Cristiano
Ronaldo is in Greece God okay here's my
belly being in good physical shape is so
attractive to me because it's the
opposite of this horrible period of time
in my life when I was injured we need to
be able to believe that I'm sexy we have
to make you a belieber I'm recreating a
Justin Bieber photo today
he's got Bieber god I assumed we were
born with somewhat similar assets he was
a smallest guy very skinny you know to
his credit he worked out a lot but this
photo got a lot of heat because it was
it was photoshopped pretty heavily I
don't know who decided but they made
Bieber more ripped and they they made
his bulge bigger even bigger Steve you
went from afford to like a seven and a
half now is it a poor come on man
getting makeup professionally done only
confirms my greatest fear that I have a
big fat baby hey so I'm recreating the
Magic Mike XXL poster Channing Tatum
front and center a triple threat really
good-looking can model can act can dance
films like Magic Mike series it is part
of this enjoyment of the perfect male
physique every guy wants abs but they're
just so hard to get first you have to
eat a certain way then you can't drink
do you drink beer
I'm of the opinion that these things are
attainable if you have the time and the
money and the team to constantly workout
and get that eight pack abs it's just no
one's that rich or has that much time
except for celebrities and actors and
models it's not our job to look that
good let's take some photos
man masculine masculine masculine
masculine I want you to walk into it so
first one so try to make it with a
little more natural don't think I've
ever looked at myself and been like [ __ ]
yeah oh you [ __ ] I feel like I'm not
masculine enough although I was told
that I look good in a tank top which is
great because I'm terrified wearing a
tank top because the tank top shows your
arms often if you don't have any arms to
show off then you're just like hey look
at me come out of shape look at the
gangly new man last side you look really
sad now you look scared we're gonna have
to maybe define the muscles a little bit
more make him look more like in good
good that looks great yeah yeah Channing
Tatum
I just know that there's so much about
me that is not up to par that was really
close who is this tough weather people
think you look good or you don't like
anyone can have problems with how they
look hopefully we have at least one that
looks kind of like the Channing Tatum
photo so when we send this to the
retoucher we're probably gonna have to
stitch his body from different frames
and put them together so he wasn't
actually jumping yeah yeah Yeah right
now we're comparing ourselves to this
image of someone who's like beautifully
sculpted that's in the end not the most
healthy thing to do just like be
Cristiano ya look pretty good amazing
with makeup and lighting can do for you
this is the way his body looks not
because he's an underwear model but
because he is a professional sports
player kind of looks like he's like
looking at something in the distance
yeah like sexually like he's better than
it it's hard to do all this but also
have a neutral face I might feel
dismayed that I am
that but seeing the fantasy of that
might be really exciting I need positive
reinforcement you look great okay that
would be pretty impossible for anyone
actually to be as perfect as Cristiano
pops an egg I'll put the photo next to
the place where I'm doing push-ups you
look good kid that's before photos yeah
I feel like I'm definitely killing it
and have no self doubts about this
moment I'll tell you growing up I never
felt hot
I felt like an nerd look huggable like
Bieber supposed to look [ __ ] about
huggleball so try to look harder than I
thought it would be hopefully I think
that it's alien weird and I'm like nah
like that my body's beautiful I should
love me but I might prefer it I might
prefer it how much work do you think the
Photoshop artist is gonna have to do to
make me look like that if Bieber's
wasn't enough they're definitely gonna
have to do something to your sis bulge
probably has to be you laughing
now we have the Photoshop results so
we're gonna check them out I have this
fear of seeing the final photo and being
crushed and knowing that I can never
achieve that ideal I think I look at
Bothell I hate this photo I look like a
surprised baby I think a lot of guys use
humor as a coping mechanism if I don't
laugh at this photo then the only other
option is to feel bad about it you
haven't seen it okay oh my god
I look like a an action figure
everything that I'm insecure about has
been erased in this photo looking at
this photo now I feel like I should like
look like this like should I not be okay
with my body should should I be striving
for this when I think of my
attractiveness I think about my
personality but as guys you don't often
think of your body as sexual I think a
lot of men out there especially straight
men don't necessarily confront that as
openly as LGBT men but for me having to
always constantly deal with my
relationship in my body and navigate
that this will be really really
eye-opening
huh I was just struck with a really
great epiphany I've always wanted to
look like this
but seeing this now in front of me makes
me realize I'll always have a problem
with my body because I just thought that
my stomach still looks fat it really
shows how me being so hyper critical of
myself won't translate into being more
self-confident if you have a problem
with how you look that's a way deeper
issue than just changing your outsides
I'm excited to see it I want to see how
I look you know all swoll and sexy like
mr. Kosinski but I'm also afraid that
maybe it will make me feel worse about
myself let's see what a perfect Keith
would look like oh man look at those
arms those arms are huge man I look
strong as [ __ ] it's terrifying
I don't like that at all no one wants to
be friends with this guy it's kind of
looks like a jerk this is Brad they put
muscles on my shadow could beat me up
well I lament that my body's not better
I don't know if I really want to look
like that maybe I like my soft body more
than having good muscles means that
you're also healthy and strong that is
what I want to be as a man healthy so I
can provide for my family so that I can
carry children upstairs there's muscles
there that I do not have Christiano
Ronaldo is so rare he was like 0.01
percent of the population that looks
like that if I wanted to look like this
and have my job and like spend time with
family there's not enough hours in the
day you're just seeking to attain
something that you can never get earlier
I said that the stronger you are the
more healthy you are there's a lot of
other aspects to health that strength
doesn't encompass if I did all of the
things I would need to do to have this
sort of body I don't think I would be
healthy I will always have issues with
how I look but maybe I can lessen those
issues by focusing on things that really
matter people aren't gonna just remember
you
you have six-pack ABS they remember you
because you're a good person I'm happy
with my life why is one photo making me
think that I'm not happy with my life
I'm totally fine with who I am improve
yourself because you want to and because
you enjoy it not because you're trying
to achieve an ideal that someone has
told you you should it lots of people
out there think that like oh if you're a
guy you should just work hard be strong
if you're unhappy with your body you
change it it's like if you're unhappy
your body maybe just learn to love
yourself for more than just your body I
call these Lions penis cleavage so my
dick cleavage looks great one yeah yeah
yeah yeah